[Música]
son las ocho y veintinueve de la noche
en Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna
seguimos comentándoles los principales
hechos del día Les agradecemos su
sintonía vamos con los titulares de esta
jornada
en televisión nacional el presidente de
Francia Manuel defendió su polémica
reforma las pensiones su primera
comparecencia desde que promulgó la ley
aseguró que eran necesarias para evitar
un déficit y propuso un pacto Social
para mejorar las condiciones de los
trabajadores hubo reacciones en las
calles
mientras que continuaron los choques
armados en Sudán Egipto y emiratos
árabes Unidos anunciaron que trabajan en
una propuesta de cese el fuego entre los
militares y los paramilitares según
Naciones Unidas ya son al menos 180 los
muertos y 1800 los heridos en los tres
días de choques
la fiscalía de Estados Unidos anunció la
imputación de dos personas por abrir y
mantener operativa una comisaría ilegal
de policía en el barrio chino de
Manhattan la ciudad de Nueva York según
las autoridades operaba bajo órdenes de
la policía China y hacía seguimiento a
residentes de ese país críticos con las
autoridades de Beijing
[Música]
[Aplausos]
iniciamos en Francia porque el
presidente Manuel macron se dirigió a
los ciudadanos luego de que la polémica
reforma pensional fuese promulgada como
una ley el mandatario mostró un tono
conciliador pero se mantuvo firme en su
postura de que el cambio Es necesario Si
se quiere mantener el sistema pensional
además invitó al diálogo mientras que
los sindicatos hicieron un llamado a
mantener las movilizaciones
durante su primer discurso desde la
promulgación de la polémica reforma
pensional el presidente Emmanuel macron
se dirigió a Francia y aseguró que
aunque entiende la ira y la frustración
debido al aumento de la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años la medida es
necesaria para evitar un déficit por lo
que propuso un pacto social que prometió
revisar en 100 días
el próximo 14 de Julio debería
permitirnos hacer un balance tenemos
ante nosotros 100 días de calma unidad
ambición y acción al servicio de Francia
es nuestro deber y confío confío en que
llegaremos allí
Macro reconoció El poder del movimiento
en las calles pero condenó lo que
calificó de extremismo dijo que desde
este martes recibirá las organizaciones
empresariales comerciales y sindicales
para escuchar sus propuestas
Pero eso respondieron que macron no dio
ninguna salida de la crisis y reiteraron
que no negociarán hasta después de la
movilización de rechazo del primero de
mayo el día del trabajador que se espera
sea multitudinaria tras el discurso en
las calles de todo el país escucharon
cacero lazos y se quemaron botes de
basura a manera de protesta improvisada
no está tranquilizando al contrario está
demostrando que se burla de Francia y
los franceses porque aprueba sus
reformas de la noche a la mañana cuando
todo el mundo está en contra
macron agregó que la primera ministra
Elizabeth dará a conocer un plan
detallado para la aplicación de la ley
la próxima semana dentro de los cuales
también se incluirán temas contra la
delincuencia el fraude fiscal y el
control de la inmigración ilegal
seguimos en Francia porque los incendios
en los pirineos orientales se han
agravado por la falta de precipitaciones
y la sequía de los suelos habitantes de
la zona Están preocupados por la falta
de agua el 75% de los acuíferos
supervisados el primero de abril
registraron niveles más bajos de lo
normal una situación preocupante de cara
al verano veamos el informe
es el primer gran incendio forestal del
año las llamas comenzaron el domingo en
el sur de Francia cientos de hectáreas
fueron arrasadas en la costa
mediterránea francesa antes de
extenderse a través de la frontera con
España el ministro del interior francés
gerald Maná estuvo en el lugar de los
hechos y atribuyó el incendio al cambio
climático
estos incendios están acelerando por el
calentamiento global y por el hecho de
que este departamento no ha visto llover
desde hace cinco meses se prevé que
Francia vivirá Un verano aún más seco
que la sequía récord que sufrió el año
pasado esto se debe a que los niveles de
agua subterránea es decir el agua que se
almacena en el suelo y evita que se
seque están en mínimos históricos según
un informe reciente el 80% de los
acuíferos del país están por debajo de
los niveles normales seis botellas siete
botellas de agua en la semana El domingo
no podemos tomar hay restricciones que
están en curso desde hace mucho tiempo
pero restringir el consumo de agua
potable es la primera vez Durante este
invierno Francia vivió el periodo de
sequía más largo de su historia debido a
la falta de precipitaciones los
agricultores han tenido que regar ellos
mismos lo que ha empeorado la situación
el presidente francés Emmanuel Mako ha
pedido nuevas medidas para ahorrar el
agua y ha dicho que todos los sectores
deben reducir su consumo de agua en un
10% para 2030
continuamos en Sudán donde por tercer
día consecutivo continuaron los choques
entre los militares y los paramilitares
de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido según
Naciones Unidas ya son al menos 180 los
muertos y 1800 los heridos por los
enfrentamientos a su vez Egipto informó
que en conjunto con emiratos árabes
Unidos preparan una propuesta de cese el
fuego entre las partes más temprano la
residencia del embajador de la Unión
Europea eidan fue asaltada mientras el
funcionario estaba allí pero logró salir
ileso así se refirió el jefe de la
diplomacia europea josepburreía a la
situación
Hace unas horas el embajador de la Unión
Europea en Sudán fue agredido en su
propia residencia esto constituye una
grave violación de la convención de
Viena la seguridad de las instalaciones
y el personal diplomático es una
responsabilidad primordial de las
autoridades ciudadanasas y una
obligación en virtud del derecho
internacional
las raíces de esta nueva escalada del
conflicto en su danza remontan a 2019
con el derrocamiento del entonces
presidente Omar al bachill desde
entonces el ejército y los paramilitares
de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido
trabajaron conjuntamente Hasta los más
recientes choques en el siguiente
informe les contamos Quiénes son los
actores implicados Y por qué empezó esta
crisis política en Sudán
un enfrentamiento mortal que sumerge a
todo el país en un callejón sin salida
por un lado el general abdel fata
alburham número uno del ejército y de
Sudán desde su golpe de estado en 2021
por el otro
mohamedlo jefe del poderoso grupo
paramilitar de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido que ahora tiene sus ojos puestos
en el poder todo comenzó en diciembre de
2018 las imágenes no tienen precedentes
miles de personas salen a las calles de
las principales ciudades protestan
contra el precio del pan que subió tres
veces rápidamente Omar al bachill quien
durante tres décadas había gobernado
Sudán con puño de hierro concentra la
ira popular cuatro meses después en
abril de 2019 El dictador es derrocado
por el ejército los militares ahora
tienen la sartén por el mango en julio
del mismo año desmantelan violentamente
un campamento de protesta en jartum el
resultado 130 muertos durante el verano
invitan a los civiles a la mesa de
negociaciones resultado se firma un
acuerdo que prevé la vuelta de los
civiles al poder a finales de 2022 Pero
esto no sucederá en octubre de 2021 otro
golpe militar las autoridades de
transición se disuelven y los civiles
son expulsados Empezando por el Primer
Ministro
el general alburjane se impuso a la
población un año y medio después es un
fracaso no logró estabilizar Sudán un
país ahora plagado de luchas muy
violentas
desde la sede de la ONU en Nueva York
que el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro afirmó que dialogará con el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
sobre un posible levantamiento de las
sanciones a Venezuela el mandatario
aseguró que ese será el foco de la
Cumbre internacional sobre Venezuela
convocada por Bogotá para la próxima
semana en la que participarán
representantes de Estados Unidos Europa
y varios países de América Latina en
impuestos sanciones al gobierno de
Nicolás maduro según Petro el camino del
diálogo es el adecuado para solucionar
la crisis venezolana Caracas reaccionó
la República bolivariana de Venezuela
manifiesta la comunidad internacional
que sólo se podrá avanzar en el diálogo
político entre venezolanos Una vez que
se hayan anulado todas las medidas
coercitivas unilaterales aplicadas a
nuestro país
cambiamos de tema porque el fiscal
Federal de Brooklyn anunció las
detenciones de dos ciudadanos de origen
chino acusados de facilitar la operación
del Ministerio de seguridad pública del
país asiático para montar una estación
policial ilegal y amedrentar a
compatriotas opositores al gobierno de
Shin Pink en la misma jornada el FBI
hizo oficial las denuncias contra una
treintena de chinos la mayoría
funcionarios del mps por formar una
granja de trolls en redes sociales que
acosaban a ciudadanos radicados en
Estados Unidos que criticaban la gestión
en China Ramiro cuevalverena tiene los
detalles
parece un edificio común y corriente en
el corazón del barrio chino de bajo
Manhattan Pero dentro de él operaba una
estación de policía china no declarada
según denunciaron las autoridades
estadounidenses al fiscal de Brooklyn
comentó que en uno de los pisos se
brindaban servicios gubernamentales sin
autorización de Estados Unidos la
acusación más severa indica que este
edificio era utilizado por el Ministerio
de Seguridad Pública para operar contra
compatriotas críticos del gobierno de
shipping un hecho por el que fueron
detenidos dos ciudadanos de origen chino
las denuncias acusan a estos oficiales
del Ministerio de seguridad pública de
participar en esquemas de represión
transnacional dirigidos a miembros de la
comunidad de la diáspora china en la
ciudad de Nueva York y en otras partes
del país
los acusados fueron identificados como
luciane One y Chen Pin Pin Quienes
fueron arrestados bajo los cargos de
Conspiración y obstrucción a la justicia
por eliminar presuntos contactos
telefónicos con el Ministerio de
seguridad público chino
Además este lunes el FBI oficializó las
denuncias contra una treintena de
funcionarios chinos por montar una
granja de trolls en redes sociales para
agredir a opositores y críticos del
gobierno de jin el director del FBI
repudió el accionar de los acusados
todas estas personas son agentes que
apoyan la campaña del gobierno chino
para exportar la represión y socavar el
estado de derecho en todo el mundo
incluso aquí mismo en Estados Unidos
dentro de los apuntados se encuentran
ocho personas que están prófugas y que
están involucradas en una causa de 2020
sobre intervención de reuniones de video
remotas que conmemoraban la masacre
detienen de 1989 en otras noticias el
portavoz de seguridad Nacional de la
Casa Blanca arremetió contra el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva y aseguró que repite como un
loro la propaganda de Rusia china sobre
la guerra en Ucrania las declaraciones
llegan luego de que Lula visitara China
y emiratos árabes Unidos el domingo
desde abu dhabi aseguró que Washington
debería dejar de incentivar la guerra y
comenzar a hablar de paz el Ministerio
de relaciones exteriores de Brasil
expresó su desacuerdo con las palabras
de
justamente este lunes el canciller ruso
sergei llegó a Brasilia donde volvió a
responsabilizar a occidente y a la otan
de lo que Rusia ha califica de operación
militar especial en Ucrania Laura se
reunió con su homólogo brasileño Mauro
vieyra con quien discutió la relación de
ambas naciones y otros asuntos de la
agenda global desde Río de Janeiro
Valeria sacónico responsable de France
24 nos amplió sobre la relación de estas
naciones en medio de las tensiones con
Washington
la visita a Brasil del ministro de
exteriores rusos ergui labrov se produce
en un momento de fuerte tensiones entre
Brasil y Estados Unidos por la postura
del presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva sobre el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania es sabido que
lulaculpa de alguna forma occidente a la
propia Ucrania por esta guerra siempre
suele decir que dos no se pelean si uno
no quiere pero hay Ahora hay otros
elementos sólo acaba de volver de China
vemos que quiere relanzar la figura de y
el papel de su país a nivel
internacional pero se mueve en un
territorio muy complicado donde es
difícil agradar a todos parecería que
Brasil estaría alejándose de su
tradicional postura neutral en el
momento en que Lula sugiere que el dólar
sea sustituido por otra moneda en las
transacciones comerciales
internacionales también sabemos que
Brasil depende mucho de los
fertilizantes de Rusia para
su sector fundamental de la economía que
es el agronegocio entonces no es fácil
condenar la posición de Rusia a pesar de
que Lula ha dicho en más de una ocasión
que se opone a que el país de Vladimir
Putin se quede con los territorios
ocupados entonces vemos a un Brasil que
intenta recobrar protagonismo tras
cuatro años de ostracismo y de perfil
bajo de la era bolsonaro pero el
escenario no es fácil y la pregunta es
silula contribuirá a crear un
multipolarismo para evitar aquella
división tradicional entre Estados
Unidos y Rusia así llegamos al final de
esta emisión de directo a América aquí
en France 24 a ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía y los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros que ya llegamos con toda la
información del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]